sanctions never worked
[Music]
they've never worked I've been studying
it for 10 15 years I studied them in
South Africa they were not the reason
for the downfall of apartheid the only
time the sanction ever worked when the
Americans sanctioned Britain during
sewers by cutting off our foreign
exchange markets um we immediately
stopped that is the only case
um Nick Mulder in his great book on this
subject could find for sanctions a
sanction having an effect sanctions
depend upon an assumption that by
altering the terms of trade altering the
commercial life of a country you affect
its politics since the politics of the
country's concern are almost by
definition ones we disagree with
um we hate we dislike they are in some
sense immune to the Democratic forces of
pressure from below almost by definition
a country that you sanction is not going
to be success susceptible to that sort
of sanction nor are they
um if you want to find a really secure
regime around the world choose the as we
sanction
Cuba Afghanistan
Myanmar Venezuela all these countries
that we sanction over time we've got 30
SEC countries at the moment under some
form of Western sanction whatever's
happening to those countries the the
regimes are not falling uh the reason
why this is coming to prominence now is
because of Russia we've sanctioned a
very big serious economy rather than a
tin pot one where we can hurt the poor
uh feel good and not change the
government in the case of Russia um we
sanctioned a serious country that could
hit back it has hit back it has arguably
caused us more disruption and
dislocation three heads of state in the
Western countries have had to have lost
their lost office since sanctions were
imposed Fusion is nowhere near losing
office the whole thing is an absurdity
sanctions are about hurting usually poor
people by rich people they are extremely
regressive form of war and is the form
of War
um they are an immoral thing in my view
you should not use uh the the the the
starvation or the deprivation of poor
people in the country or for that matter
oligarchs in a country
um as a way of trying to change someone
else's government that you don't like
um you have I have to say to say to
yourself anyway why is it our
responsibility to change your government
that we happen not to like but that's a
separate issue and we could discuss that
later but the fact is you've got a
weapon which sounds good makes you feel
good uh um is is is is is lends itself
to Media rhetoric about devastating
sanctions disruptive sanctions we're
ruining them the fact is it never
happens that way it has never happened
that way and it ought to stop and I wish
if I can say one thing but my colleagues
on the on the platform be quite nice
with think tanks sometimes grappled with
this I have been to think tanks at both
their Think Tank
um meetings on sanctions and they always
discuss how much they hurt they never
discuss do they work
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas